meine these heute abend ist der
russische staatshaushalt erzielt trotz
sanktionen deutliches plus ist nicht nur
eine these sondern eine feststellung ich
wünschte mir diese nachricht käme von
einer russischen propaganda seite doch
die quelle ist der deutschlandfunk muss
dann halt nach offiziellen angaben im
ersten halbjahr trotz krieg und
sanktionen ein haushaltsüberschuss von
mehr als 20 milliarden euro erzielt es
ist eine bittere wahrheit die wehtut
aber die auch viele sanktions gegner
früh vorausgesagt haben hintergrund ist
der gestiegene ölpreis von dem russland
profitiert die westlichen sanktionen
haben bislang vor allem den import
westlicher waren nach russland erschwert
es gibt ökonomen die sagen dass die
sanktionen einfach länger zeit brauchen
sie brauchen noch etwas um die wirkung
zu erzielen aber wie lange soll
deutschland das noch durchhalten während
länder wie beispielsweise china oder
auch indien fröhlich weiter geschäfte
mit russland machen es ist möglich dass
wir mit den sanktionen vor allem uns
selbst schwächen erfahren heute wie es
sind ihre zwischenbilanz jetzt wer 138
tagen krieg nun bei den sanktionen muss
man natürlich unterscheiden wir haben
eine reihe von sanktionen
eine haben wir eben nicht und das ist
der gasimport nach europa der ist nicht
sanktioniert und trotzdem müssen wir
damit rechnen dass uns der gas zu strom
abgestellt wird im augenblick glaube ich
sehen die chancen nicht so schlecht aus
er habe persönlich für das gut hat in
kanada interveniert und hat gesagt wir
brauchen die verdichterstation die soll
ich liefert werden damit wieder gas
fließen kann wenn es dazu nicht kommt
und
das weiß man natürlich nicht als lenski
hat ja protestiert und hat bei der
kanadischen regierung protest eingelegt
dann wird es dazu kommen dass wir nicht
nur ein problem des heizens haben dann
haben wir ein problem mit unserer
gesamten volkswirtschaft denn sagen dass
die sanktionen bislang gewirkt haben
verhängt wurden ich glaube schon ich
meine dass der druck ist enorm und beim
gas haben wir eben eine ein ergebnis von
10 jähriger falscher energiepolitik wir
haben uns leider in einer abhängigkeit
begeben weil wir erstens die kernenergie
abgestellt haben zweitens die kohle aber
worin sehen sie dass diese aktion
wirklich
die zahlen jetzt hier angucke und auch
nur die meldung in deutschland von
russischer staatshaushalt erzielt trotz
sanktionen deutliches plus da muss man
entweder sagen sind die zahlen aus dem
russischen finanzministerium falsch oder
man muss sagen die sanktionen haben
mitgewirkt oder her sind ja nicht nur
das ist ja nicht nur der staatshaushalt
sondern ich glaube schon dass die
russischen bürger merken dass sie viele
produkte nicht mehr bekommen dass die
restlichen importe fehlen und dass auch
produkte in russland fehlen weil chips
import gibt es auch nicht mehr aber für
uns ist doch jetzt wirklich allerhöchste
zeit man mit einigen tabus aufzuräumen
das wird in so leid einem das tut wir
müssen da durch ohne dieses gas werden
wir wird dieses land zerstört und dann
werden wir auch nicht in der lage sein
ukraine irgendwelche hilfen weiter
zurück zu geben sondern am ende wird
wird es so sein dass wir das gar nicht
mehr bezahlen können denn wir reden über
fünf
sicherheit nicht so viel gebracht wie
man sich am anfang versprochen hat und
jetzt auch verkündet worden ich habe
heute noch im ohr v annalena baerbock
unsere außenministerin sagt diese
sanktionen werden russland in den ruin
treiben also russland werden ruiniert
das wird überhaupt ausfallen als welt
politischer ökonomischer player davon
kann überhaupt nicht die rede sein wir
lesen sie zum beispiel putzige
geschichten dass also der versuchen eine
balance zu kopieren offenbar gescheitert
sei es gibt also schmeckt und punkt und
die internetseiten sind voll von
russischen nutzern dieser nachgemacht
der amerikanische produkte sagen
bisschen schlechter sei was vergammelt
der salat 25 jahren leider nicht kaputt
damen wird russland nicht kaputt gehen
auch von weniger champagner und weniger
seife wird man nicht kaputt gehen also
man hat dann einfach von deutscher seite
den mund zu voll genommen ich bin
überhaupt kein gegner der sanktionen
natürlich muss man allem was vernünftig
ist russland entgegensetzen allem was
vernünftig sind die sanktionen noch von
ich glaube wir sind jetzt so langsam
einen punkt wo wir überlegen müssen ob
das ausmaß der sanktionen möglich zu
einer wende des krieges von dem wir uns
alle hoffen dass sie zugunsten der
ukraine ausfällt beitragen wird ich
würde sagen dazu tragen eher
waffenlieferungen bei als diese sanktion
es ist doch ganz klar wir reden immer
von die globalisierung die
globalisierung im osten
weshalb google funktioniert ja doch also
russland kann mit china handeltreiben
mit indien wir wissen dass die mehrzahl
der bevölkerung der welt an der
sanktionen überhaupt nicht beteiligt ist
das heißt man hat den mund ich muss
wiederholen zu voll genommen man wird
allein mit sanktionen den krieg nicht
zugunsten der ukraine beenden können
deswegen plädiere ich eben dafür stärker
was man schon hätte früher machen sollen
auf eine militärische unterstützung zu
setzen wie blicken sie auf die sanktion
der ampel regierung hat die ampeln guten
job gemacht
ich glaube dass es völlig richtig ist
hier scharfe sanktionen auszusprechen
und ich will noch mal sagen wir sitzen
hier wohl behütet in einem durchaus gut
klimatisierten studio und reden über die
frage eines angriffskrieges eines
barbarischen angriffskrieges und ich
würde das gerne auch mal ins verhältnis
setzen heute morgen gerade eine junge
familie hier in berlin getroffen die
seit wochen privat untergebracht war und
jetzt den schritt in die eigenen vier
wände geht als ich mit der mutter 44
gesprochen habe erzählte sie wirklich
erschreckend unter tränen was sie alles
in kiew verloren hat nämlich alles und
das will ich noch mal deutlich machen
dass es deshalb wichtig ist dass wir auf
der einen seite auch wenn es zu unseren
eigenen lasten geht so hart das ist
sanktionen rechtfertigen
können sie mir sagen ob erfolg erzielt
wurde wir sehen ja dass wir eine
instabilität bekommen wir haben wir
gerade über die frage der wechselkurse
gesprochen die sie kurz an getippt haben
in der frage was wird da eigentlich in
russland in den medien diskutiert sie
sagen dass der rubel stabil ist an das
hängt mit den dividenden zusammen was
die wechselkurse betrifft dass wir
solche nachrichten bekommen also wer
genau hinschaut und sich auch das bibb
anschaut der wird sehen dass durchaus
die sanktionen eine wirkung haben und es
völlig richtig dass sanktionen immer
wieder hinterfragt werden und das tut
auch die bundesregierung im vergleich
zum euro hat sich der rubel jetzt nicht
dass man sagen kann deutlich schlechter
damit ja ich meine damit dass wenn man
sich das insgesamt anschaut durchaus
festhalten muss dass das land ja keine
größere stabilität durch die sanktionen
gewonnen hat
so rösel auch die instabilität wir genau
erreichen stehen eine größere stadt
richtig aber ihre these bei ihnen ist ja
eine gegenthese sie sagen ja die
sanktionen führen nicht dazu dass es
eine instabile treten es gibt sondern
sie machen sogar den punkt drauf und
sagen sie haben eher den eindruck dass
das land stabiler ist als der euroraum
mit dem euro ich habe gesagt ihre these
sie gesagt habe huber wäre geschwächt
und da habe ich gesagt nein der euro
wurde auch geschwächt im innersten
relation zueinander sid ich kann
wirklich nicht erkenntnis konnte ich mir
noch kein politiker in der runde bislang
erklären wo die sanktionen jetzt
wirklich gewirkt haben also dass sie
wirklich hundertprozentig gewirkt haben
das konnten sie mir auch nicht erklären
gerade
nun sitze ich nicht im
verteidigungsausschuss bin ich mitglied
des deutschen bundestages ich kann ihnen
sagen was wir intern diskutieren auf der
ebene auch der
fraktionsvorsitzendenkonferenz zum
austausch der bund länder weil wir
natürlich jeden tag auch mit den fragen
der bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht
konfrontiert sind was tut ihr da und was
hat das für auswirkungen auf unser leben
hier vor ort wir sehen das jetzt bei den
steigenden energiepreisen wir sehen es
bei den lebenshaltungskosten
wir sehen das ja in dem alltäglichen
jedes einzelnen hier im inland und von
daher müssen wir uns jeden tag diese
frage auch stellen lassen was diese
sanktionen bringen wie sehr kann man in
den zahlen glauben weil das ist
natürlich schon eine wichtige frage wie
weit kann man sich darauf verlassen dass
ihr zweiter beispielsweise in
deutschland von gemeldet hat na ja ich
glaube schon dass man sich auf die
zahlen verlassen kann und man kann ja
sehen wo der rubel steht man kann sehen
wie sich die wirtschaft entwickelt das
sind zahlen die realistisch sind ich
glaube es ist ganz einfach so lange es
keine öl- und gas-embargo es gibt wird
russland weiterhin so gut dastehen oder
schlecht dastehen wie es momentan der
fall ist und da kann man natürlich die
position vertreten und sagen wir können
nicht ohne russisches gas wir können
nicht ohne öl aber das bedeutet dann
auch gleichzeitig eben dass russland
nicht so sehr darunter leiden wird ich
glaube dennoch dass man mittelfristig
sicherlich dort ergebnisse sehen wird
insbesondere im hochtechnologiebereich
also all das was du vielleicht ist der
ökonom bei die sagen es braucht einfach
länger des heiligen berges braucht
definitiv längere zeit aber man muss ja
davon ausgehen auch was der künstler
gesagt hat die deutsche regierung hat es
so verkauft als würde ist jetzt
passieren und russland würde jetzt
geschwächt und das ist ja auch das was
man eigentlich bräuchte ja das ziel war
ja russland zu schwächen druck auszuüben
dass der krieg in der ukraine beendet
wird
das ist nicht der fall das ist definitiv
so das ist das problem ich glaube
dennoch nicht dass das dazu führen dazu
sagen ja dann war das falsch wir nehmen
jetzt mal sanktionen zurück ja ich halte
auch das argument andere machen
geschäfte mit russland
für kein argument was uns interessieren
sollte weil ich finde schon dass wir als
deutschland natürlich eine auch einen
moralischen kompass haben müssen die
anderen romanischen komplette also ich
glaube dass china an anderen moralischen
kompass hat als deutschland ich meine
die spanier die im augenblick lustig gas
aus russland erhöhen 25 prozent der
spanier den spanischen gases kommt aus
russland
bei uns geht es runter bei der geht's
rauf und polen hat sich über nord stream
1 eingedeckt hat ihre lager voll unsere
lager sind nicht voll aber sie haben ja
schon immer da aber über die das drama
der deutschen energiepolitik gesprochen
ja das war die spd die uns dorthin
gebracht wir sowieso merkel mitte ist
mit mit der mit der spd ich glaube das
ist schon viel früher angefangen hat
auch vor frau merkel und auch teilweise
wird ja absolut einmal jetzt sind wir
eben da wo wir sind von daher halte ich
sozusagen zu sagen okay wir müssen uns
mal vorstellen der krieg des 138 tage
alt und wie deutschland fangen jetzt an
schon zu sagen ach das hilft ja alles
nichts und das ist schlecht und die
sanktionen und jetzt wollen wir aber
nicht mehr uns geht ist wahnsinnig gut
ja muss das noch mal aufgerafft ich mich
wie gesagt vor dem tagen aus der ukraine
zurückgekehrt im donbass ist dramatisch
weiterhin verliert die ukraine da
territorium menschen stirbt ja dann
kennen wir aber ja ein bisschen wieder
in die korona schleife hauptsache wir
machen was und ob die wirkung jetzt da
ist oder nicht ist egal also müssen die
sanktionen nicht wirklich zielgerichtet
sein um auch schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
normal also entweder macht man öl und
gas sanktionen oder es wird so
weitergehen da kann man jetzt noch
zielgerichteter reingehen und man kann
ja die position vertreten und sagen in
deutschland braucht russisches gas und
öl okay ich glaube man sollte
drastischer sein das ist meine
persönliche meinung allerdings wenn man
jetzt sagt okay wir sagen zu den hier
noch ein bisschen da noch ein bisschen
ich glaube man müsste noch viel härter
auf personenbezogene sanktionen und
bedingt ich glaube so zu sagen man muss
die oligarchen töchter und familie noch
viel breiter treffen weil ich glaube
schon dass das dazu führt dass dieser
moment mal also jetzt gar nicht mehr im
westen urlaub machen das will ich also
ich glaube man da kann man sicherlich
noch was tun aber generell ist die große
frage was ist mit öl und gas